mac and cheese mac and cheese America
yeah hell yeah I'm gonna try the mac and
cheese yeah let's try it I'm kind of a
snob when it comes to mac and cheese me
too
[Music]
yeah
that is not a quality magazine this is
not a quality mac and cheese I don't
know whoever made it I'm sorry if
they're offended but that's the
drizzling the British person making a
mac and cheese yeah that's a drizzling
what's it missing
um flavor
it's just like I don't know it's very
very
please take this away yeah that's an
epic fail because like it has like an
opportunity like my mac and cheese that
I make as a crispy crust it's layered
there's different cheeses
the noodles are cooked better like it's
an emotional experience you have my Mac
and Cheese yeah you're having a move
that was an emotional experience but not
in a good way get it together England
you're embarrassing me